boris johnson has tonight sent two
offshore patrol vessels to jersey
after the french government threatened
to cut off electricity
in a row over post-brexit fishing rides
jersey is a self-governed
dependency which is geographically
closer to france than to britain
the island receives 95 percent of its
electricity from france through undersea
cables
well tonight's announcement follows a
day of both sides blaming
the other if yeah it is important that
we can denounce immediately and i've
done it with the commission
the non-respect of this brexit agreement
because if we accept it in jersey it is
dangerous for all of our access
as you know the agreement provides for
retaliatory measures and these measures
we are ready to use
europe france has means they are
inscribed in the agreement
as far as jersey is concerned i'll
remind you of electricity transportation
via undersea
cable i think the threat that was made
is um you know would be completely
disproportionate and is obviously
unacceptable i mean we are working
through the
uh the agreement jersey have already
licensed over 40 vessels
they've been very pragmatic throughout
this
they've also been clear that um they'll
process the remaining 17 or so that have
applied as soon as they
put forward the data so i think it's you
know unacceptable to make those
uh those sorts of comments
guys political correspondent kate mccann
joins us now is this sounding serious
kate
it is quite serious there are those two
vessels sent by the uk government to
monitor the situation but clearly the
threat from france the possible blockade
which is due to start tomorrow that's
why the timing of this tonight
is so crucial from the uk side is
significant here
there is a sense speaking to people
behind the scenes in downing street that
actually
the uk government has tried repeatedly
to engage with the french diplomatically
on this issue but that hasn't so far
been possible that offer still stands of
course it's jersey's right to set its
own licences when it comes to fishing
but the real problem here and it's a
similar one
to one that we've seen before with
northern ireland is that when policy on
brexit was made very quickly
there were some issues which were very
tangled which were very historical and
actually quite complicated
which have since come to light where
resolution hasn't necessarily
been possible this is one of them the
french from january when this
granville bay treaty was moved to the
side when the new european uk
agreement was put in place they were
saying then that they were going to
appeal to the european union to put back
in place the treaty that they wanted to
see continue they were talking about war
at that point
clearly over the last couple of months
this issue has ramped up and ramped up
and now we are at a point
where the uk government sees the only
option having tried repeatedly for a
diplomatic route
is to send those two vessels important
to say they are monitoring the situation
there's nothing active involved tonight
but clearly an escalation and not one
that the uk side would want to see